feel that i have
something bigger inside me that wants to
go out but in the same time i have
something that is keeping me at a
certain level maybe it's it's here it's
overthinking yeah fear like the fear of
whatever they could see here yeah that's
that's this yeah at the end of the day
everybody else is worried about their
own life so if you stumble if you stink
yeah they may leave a comment here and
there but deep down they don't care thus
it should be easy for you to do because
their judgment shouldn't matter to you
because you have to realize it doesn't
matter to them and you just need to
change these like it's a mindset and you
change it and that's it or it's a
practice so that you can understand that
i mean both it's a fixed mindset to get
you to start
once you start you realize it's not that
scary people were scared to ride bikes
people were scared to swim people were
scared to kiss a boy and a girl they
were scared
then they did it they weren't scared
that's it
thank you much you're welcome you're
welcome